the essence of philosophy is that a man
should so live that his happiness shall
depend as little as possible on external
things people are not disturbed by
things but by the views they take of
them a city is not adorned by external
things but by the virtue of those who
dwell in
it he who exercises wisdom exercises
knowledge of
God to accuse others of One's Own
Misfortune is a sign of lack of
Education to accuse oneself shows that
one's education has begun to accuse
neither oneself nor others shows that
one's education is
complete in every Affair consider what
precedes and what follows then take
action those proficient praise no one
blame no one and accuse no
[Music]
one difficult ities reveal the character
of
men events happen as they do people
behave as they are Embrace what you
get neither call yourself a philosopher
nor talk among the unlearned about
theorems but act according to
[Music]
them when anyone provokes you be assured
that it is your opinion that provokes
you lameness is an impediment of the leg
not of the
will be free from grief not through
insensibility like irrational animals
nor through want of thought like the
foolish but like a man of virtue by
having reason as the consolation of
grief for fortify yourself with
contentment this is an impregnable
Fortress it is better to do wrong seldom
and to own it than to do wrong often but
never admit
it keep your attention focused entirely
on what is truly your own concern and be
clear that what belongs to others is
their business and none of
yours
most of what passes for legitimate
entertainment is inferior and foolish
and only caters to or exploits people's
weaknesses death is nothing terrible
else it would have appeared so to
Socrates but the terror consists in our
notion of death that it is
[Music]
terrible he is a wise man who does not
grieve for the things which he has not
but rejoices for those things which he
has no man is free who's not master of
[Music]
himself what is the first business of
one who practices philosophy to get rid
of
self-conceit for it is impossible for
anyone to begin to learn that which he
thinks he already
knows
first say to yourself what you would be
then do that what you have to
do since it is reason Which shapes and
regulates all other things it ought not
itself to be left to
disorder you can be Invincible if you
never enter into a contest that you
cannot
win reason is not measured by size or
height but by
[Music]
principle nothing great is created
suddenly any more than a bunch of grapes
or a
fig the origin of Sorrow is this to wish
for something that never comes to
pass freedom is secured not by the
fulfilling of men's desires but but by
the removal of
desire in theory there is nothing to
hinder our following what we are taught
but in life there are many things that
distract
us the key is to keep company only with
people who uplift you whose presence
brings out your
best if you are in pain you will find
fortitude if you hear unpleasant
language you will find
patience if you seek truth you will not
seek to gain a victory by every possible
means and when you have found truth you
need not fear being
[Music]
defeated decide to be extraordinary and
do what you need to do
now suffering arises es from trying to
control the
uncontrollable or from neglecting what
is within your power to
do no matter what happens it is within
my power to turn it to my
advantage nothing is in reality either
Pleasant or unpleasant by Nature All
Things become so through
[Music]
habit things in our control are opinion
Pursuit desire aversion and in a word
whatever our own actions
are if you want to improve prepare to be
thought foolish and
[Music]
stupid attach yourself to what is
spiritually Superior regardless of what
other people think or do hold to your
true aspirations no matter what is going
going on around
you freedom is the only worthy goal in
life it is one by disregarding things
that lie beyond your
control nature ha given men one tongue
and two ears that we may hear from
others twice as much as we
speak true instruction is this to learn
to wish that each thing should come to
pass as it
does we should not Moore a ship with a
single anchor nor our life with a single
hope have this thought ever present
within thee when thou losest any outward
thing what thou gainst in
instead when you are offended at any
man's fault turn to yourself and study
your own failings then you will forget
your
[Music]
anger everything has two handles the one
by which it may be carried and the other
by which it
cannot to you all you have seems small
to me all I have seems great your desire
is insatiable mine is
satisfied
he who laughs at himself never runs out
of things to laugh
at there is only one way to happiness to
cease worrying about things which are
beyond your
[Music]
control give me by all means the shorter
and nobler life rather than the longer
and baser
one if you ever happen to turn your
attention to externals for the pleasure
of anyone be assured that you have
ruined your scheme of
Life seek not the good in external
things seek it in
yourself you are but an image and not
the thing you appear to
[Music]
be the philosopher School ye men is a
surgery you ought not to go out of it
with pleasure but with pain for you were
not in Sound Health When you
entered no man is able to make progress
when he is wavering between two
[Music]
opposites practice the little things
then proceed to the greater
ones
it is my business to manage carefully
and dexterously whatever
happens freedom and slavery the one is
the name of virtue the other of Vice
both are acts of the
Will You Are Not Alone nay God is within
and your Genius is
within is freedom anything else than the
power of living as we
choose first learn the meaning of what
you say then
speak circumstances don't make the man
they only reveal
him of Pleasures those which are the
most common rarely give the most
Delight remember that you ought to
behave in life as you would at a
banquet any person capable of angering
you becomes your
master you are a little soul carrying a
corpse as for sex abstain as far as
possible before marriage and if you do
partake of it do nothing that is
socially unacceptable
[Music]
h